im achtzehnten und neunzehnten
jahrhundert fand in europa eine
evolution statt
dabei ging es nicht um kriege macht oder
politik sondern um güter mit hilfe von
wasser und dampfkraft konnten stoffe
plötzlich schneller hergestellt
kohle leichter gefördert und stahl
besser verarbeitet werden
im nachhinein bezeichnen wir das als
erste industrielle revolution die
einführung der elektrizität leitete wind
später die zweite industrielle
revolution ein
fließbänder wurden erst in den
schlachthöfen von cincinatti eingesetzt
bis sie zu beginn des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts von henry ford für die
produktion seines modells perfektioniert
wurden menschliche arbeit im akkord in
den 1970 er jahren hielt eine neuartige
erfindung einzug in die industrie
der computer erlaubte es industrie
roboter zu programmieren und damit zu
steuern
mit der automatisierung wird die dritte
industrielle revolution markiert heute
ändert sich die arbeitswelt erneut wir
befinden uns im übergang zur industrie
4.0
[Musik]
im rahmen vom wissenschafts jahr 2018
arbeitswelten der zukunft schaue ich mir
zusammen mit lisa vom kanal die
klugscheißer rinn verschiedene zukunfts
orte an der erste dieser zukunfts orte
befindet sich in kaiserslautern
hier ist die smart factory eine
forschungsanlage die zeigt wie eine
fabrik der zukunft aussehen könnte und
wie diese ganzen die richtige
funktionieren das weiß professor
buschkowsky wir stehen hier in der dass
marktakteure kaiserslautern das ist so
ein bisschen der geburtsstätte von dem
was wir heute als industrie 40 kennen
hier sind es schon vor über 15 jahren
die ersten ideen loswerden jemand eine
produktion so aufbauen kann dass man
individuelle produkte fertigen kann also
ich möchte mein eigenes fahrrad man
eigenes auto mein eigenes man die
visitenkarten halter konkret bei uns
nicht fertigen und wir haben es damals
gedanken darüber gemacht wie muss
eigentlich eine fabrik aufgebaut sein
dass sie in der lage ist ja auch mein
eigenes produkt zu reagieren und das
entsprechend zu fertigen und da kam der
gedanke die maschine nicht wie es heute
oder bis in der vergangenheit üblich war
fest miteinander zu verkoppeln sondern
die miteinander reden zu lassen
also bei uns haben wir eine modulare
produktionsanlage werden also diese
fertigung in einzelne schritte zerlegt
in einzelne module die man hier
entsprechend auch sieht kann man bei uns
relativ gut optisch erkennen diese
einzelne module und haben dafür gesorgt
dass jedes modul nur ein
produktionsschritt durchführt und dass
die module miteinander entsprechend
kommunizieren können das heißt die reden
sogar mit meinem produkt
in der smart factory werden
visitenkarten halter hergestellt das ist
natürlich so ein beispiel um eine
produktion mit mehreren arbeitsschritten
zu simulieren
der clou an diesem modularen aufbau ist
die flexibilität genau wir können also
module jederzeit austauschen wir können
sie sogar im laufenden betrieb die
module rausnehmen
wir haben die schleusen zwischen modulen
die sich dann automatisch schließen
wir können mehr module einführen wir
können die linie auseinanderziehen ein
weiteres modul einfügen
zum beispiel hat man ja auch das problem
ein produktionsschritt dauert länger als
ein anderer
dann kann ich für diesen
produktionsschritt anderen zweites
module einbauen
und genau das nächste freie modul nimmt
sich entsprechend das bauteil
man ist also da sehr flexibel und kann
die anlage jederzeit anpassen
man kann als auch vorher neue
produktions module bauen und tauschten
innerhalb von minuten einfach aus und
die bringen sich in einem
produktionsprozess sein
das funktioniert mit hilfe von rfid
chips jeder visitenkarten halter startet
mit diesem chip
hier werden daten wie die
produktionsnummer gespeichert aber auch
details zur herstellung zum beispiel
welche farbe das gehäuse haben soll
der vorteil dieses systems jedes modul
und jeder arbeiter kann mit hilfe eines
lesegeräts abfragen wie dieses produkt
einmal aussehen soll wird am produkt
gearbeitet dann werden die änderungen
anschließend auf dem chip vermerkt so
kann zum beispiel auch der kleine
hilfsflotte der smart factory teile
entgegennehmen und an die richtige
stelle bringen ohne mit den modulen oder
einer zentrale kommunizieren zu müssen
der vorteil ist erneut flexibilität das
ist genau der punkt weil müssen wir klar
sein die hauptkosten in der produktion
sind gar nicht unbedingt die
produktionskosten selber sondern die
kosten außen rum
das heißt überhaupt die aufbau der
produktion umbau oder produktion die
ganze planung der produkte
das ist heute noch sehr sehr
arbeitsaufwendige sache das wird
teilweise mit excel tabellen oder auf
papier geplant das wird gar nicht
wirklich von programmen unterstützt
und wenn man dieses alles flexibilisiert
und automatisiert die abläufe
automatisiert dann kann man die kosten
der produktion deutlich runter bringen
wir können viel schneller produzieren
wir können viel flexibler umstellen kann
ein produkt aus luft und das ist
eigentlich aus dem den großen reiz
ausmacht und das ziel ist eigentlich
dazu kommen dass wir halt nicht mehr
unsere produkte über sie fertigen lassen
und herr bringen mit sechs wochen
lieferzeit auf dem schiff sondern dass
wir zu denselben kostet in der lage sind
hier produkte zu bauen die standards
sprechen
am morgen habe ein weiterer wichtiger
punkt die produktion passt sich dem
menschen an wo wir früher hinter dem
fließband noch die sklaven der maschinen
waren wird die arbeitswelt heute humana
mit hilfe von künstlicher intelligenz
kann man zum beispiel erkennen ob ein
arbeiter fehler macht auf diese weise
wird ein erfahrener elektriker nicht
immer und immer wieder auf dieselbe
warnung hingewiesen
und falls doch ein fehler passieren
sollte dankbar sticker auf und gibt
rechtzeitig bescheid maschinen sollen
uns menschen in der fabrik der zukunft
also nicht komplett ersetzen sondern uns
auf augenhöhe unterstützen
natürlich kann das alles nicht von heute
auf morgen in den echten fabrikhallen
dieser welt so funktionieren aber
industrie 4.0 ist ein prozess und dieser
prozess ist heute schon in vollem gange
okay das war mein erstes video zum
wissenschaftsjahr weiter geht's jetzt
auf dem kanal der klugscheißer drin wo
das zweite video statt genauer wissen
gerne vorbei
viel spaß und bis dahin